like cheers coming back uh one of the
people in cheer is a big uh pedophile
he's a dark webpedo
now do they address that because that's
fun
not that he did it but the addressing of
it
let's see
they have to right i mean
i hope they do it should be every
episode
the thing about cheer is these kids are
from uh
some who cares part of texas and they're
cheerleaders and they have like they
have like
two years and they jump around on a mat
and then they go work at sonic but for
those two years they have really good
lives and everybody respects them and
all the young girls in texas are like i
want to be like you you know and then
eventually after the cheering the mess
starts you know they start yeah you know
their boyfriend starts getting thrown
them in the walls and things get real
dark real quick you know they start
doing kill tony
but
how cheers season two tackles jerry
harris's sexual abuse charges the
season's fifth episode offers a timeline
of the 21 year old navarro college cheer
team's members alleged sexual misconduct
with two young teens uh eventually
leading to his arrest now this is monica
uh what's her name
with her she's a legend in cheerleading
and she's an attractive woman
and i i i know like her son i think on
instagram and she's an attractive woman
and she's a beast of a cheerleading
coach and everybody likes her but and
it's not her fault but one of her star
uh cheerleaders was like uh
drizzling it
all over
in january 2020 nearly two years before
harris was accused of child sexual
exploitation abuse in a lawsuit
um he was prominently centered in the
docu-series first set of six episodes so
he was the one of the main characters so
now how do they handle this can we uh
this contains spoilers of season two of
cheer
um
but the season fifth uh and middle
episode dedicates itself explicitly to
these allegations his arrest and the so
we're watching that one
season two of tier fifth episode where
i'm in
his arrest and eight counts of sex
crimes involving minors
eight he's plead not guilty
um
so what they do is they do a cheer
where they
support
having sex with people your own age
so they go like they do the thing on the
head they go they go no no they go
little little no no
no no
little little had had no no
if you're that tall tall then breast
press tall talk
i hope that's how they do it
al dama recounted how she learned of
harris's sexual abuse allegations and
the initial federal charge of producing
child pornography during september 2020
harris was federally charged with an
additional seven counts in december
2020. i was on stage at dancing with the
stars in dress rehearsal for our very
first live show
the executive producer came up to me and
showed me her phone and asked me if i'd
seen the headline in the news that day
she recalled it was like an audi an
out-of-body experience at the time i
felt like i couldn't breathe i did the
show and then i went back to my trailer
i didn't even want to look at my phone
because i was scared i couldn't do
anything about it and i just didn't want
to read it she added before revealing
that the team at a meeting that night
about the news which she described as
being a tear-filled funeral
towards the end of the episode the
navoro cheer coach reveals harris sent
her a letter which she describes as
optimistic and features his desire to
become a motivational speaker wait what
towards the end of the episode
hold on
towards the end of the episode the
devorah cheer coach reveals that harris
sent her a letter which she describes as
optimistic and futures his desire to
become a motivational speaker so i think
that was the end of season one this was
what they're saying i don't think so
towards the end of the episode
this we're talking about the episode
i believe it's
like i think he's
would it be great
i used to [ __ ] kids
but now
i realize that i had to invest in myself
you can do anything you want to do
i remember when i was trapped
in a prison of negativity i was [ __ ]
kids but then
i realized
that i could hustle
and grind and figure it out
wow
it's sad it's sad for him that he's got
this disease it's sad for the kids it's
sad for dead aldama she you know but
here's what's not sad for the viewers
we don't want
i mean i hate you know
it's bad
it's not good i don't even want to go
into this because it's like
you know it's like stomach churning
stuff he's victimizing children but
pleading not guilty but i'm gonna watch
that episode because it's the only
episode i'm interested in because i
don't really care about cheerleading or
these people's lives
but seeing them all react to this is
kind of interesting
right i'm not saying i'm happy it
happened i'm clearly not
but as a viewer to watch them react to
this to me is interesting
how does a cheer team handle it how does
a texas
cheer team
handle it
here's the real reality
he's a pedophile
did he take vitamins
did he take nad did he do nadra did he
do high dose vitamin c high dose vitamin
d vitamin d cures pedophilia
vitamin d cures pedophilia
if you take
vitamin d
zinc
serotonin and then ivermectin
you start [ __ ] adults